I think that our parents generation from
democracies under threat is that from
the Great Depression answer for fascism
they used democracy better they use
democracy better I had lunch a few years
ago with a retiring politician he was
very senior politician and he talked
about when he was first coming along in
Washington and he said when he was
coming along in the 60s that people
could vehemently disagree on the whole
on the floor of the House of
Representatives one day and that night
go out to dinner with each other's
families and have a good time um because
he said they'd been through so much
together the war the depression other
things they understood their commonality
across their differences but he said for
them this new crown that said the new
crowd and he meant Democrats Republicans
alike for the new crowd it's personally
said they genuinely don't like each
other that was how he put it that's true
a lot of people today that lacking the
commonalities haven't had luxury
therefore lacking common experiences
lacking a common struggle it's very easy
of us to decide there's something wrong
with people disagree with them who's
never had we've never had to experience
our human commonalities
hey